thank you so much
ted well after coming off a pair of home
wins
the golden knights are hitting the road
for the next 10 days they're going to be
quite busy
sports director chris matthews joining
us now in studio with more on their very
first stop for that hey chris how you
doing guys yeah i'll tell you what this
is the first stop and it takes them to
san jose for back-to-back games against
the sharks on friday and saturday
so they're six games in 10-day that
odyssey starts with their most hated
rivals
it's crazy in only three years these two
teams have developed a bitter rivalry
and to throw a little salt in the wood
the guy who coached the sharks to a lot
of success really
was fired then hired by vegas that's
peter deboer the knights have beaten
this team already once it was at their
place vegas won it 3-1
so you know it's going to be a heated
game once again we thought hey let's get
the sharks take
on the rivalry in the upcoming game with
vegas i can tell you the first time we
played vegas back here at home i mean
without the fans it's a little different
feel on the ice and that's just to be
honest i think
you know half of it is is the build up
in the excitement in the rink and
and the crowd and the noise um without
that
um there's still that you could see
there's still that
uh uh hatred for for each other and that
rivalry i
watched a lot of different games
especially the rivalry so uh
obviously i could see how high attention
can get and how much these teams uh
can get into each other's uh girls a
little bit so
uh obviously i know uh it's a big game
like it's a
physical game it's a fast game guys are
chirping guys they're you know trying to
get in each other's face and uh
well you know that's what the rivalry is
and that's what it's supposed to be and
that's what it's going to be
oh he is absolutely right that's what
it's going to be rivals were supposed to
be physical a little chippy and
that's what is most anticipating here
tomorrow for most of
uh most of the fans there kirsten well
yeah it does make it fun when they get
in there and throw some punches
it's only been three years but there are
some hated relationships there right
yeah you know you think about too fans
will remember the ryan reeves evander
kane rivalry within the rivalry
the postseason absolutely off the charts
remember gallant calling peter deboer a
clown
and then the sharks coming back to win
uh the game over the nights in the
postseason when they
gave up those three goals on the power
play on a bad call by the officials
that is what makes sports so fun the
rivals
certainly is my goodness all right
thanks so much chris